Single
Bon les mecs à la compta, les chiffres là c'est n'importe quoi
Ça part clairement en cacahuète!
Mais détends toi! Viens on va se boire un petit pot après le travail!
Pardon ?
Je te rappelle que demain à neuf heures j'ai une réu', une "conf call"
[Jeudi]: Ah non mais juste un petit verre
de toute façon je rentre jamais tard
A moins que ce soit une soirée étudiante
ou une soirée BDE
[Vendredi]: Alors, moi perso, si je peux un peu donner mon avis
je suis clairement hyper chaud pour sortir...
... et me défoncer la gueule
Donc Jeudi tu viens...
... Mercredi tu viens ou pas?
[Mercredi]: Ah bah non les mecs, je peux pas, moi,  je m'occupe des enfants, comme d'hab', hein
[Samedi]: Moi, je suis chaud!
Aller, tout le monde sort là!
Appellez Lundi!
[Vendredi]: Ah non, pas Lundi...
Putain, tu sais comment il est...
*musique triste*
[Lundi]: Ma vie est nulle!
Le travail reprend
Laissez-moi seul
[Vendredi]: Et allez, il recommence...
[Samedi]: Aller Lundi là, sors avec nous là!
Allez ho!
Même Jeudi est chaud pour venir avec nous
[Jeudi]: Moi je rends vers 23 heures, minuit, si ça vous dérange pas...
...sinon, demain je vais être mal
[Vendredi]: Pas faux
[Lundi]: Laissez-moooooiiii
[Samedi]: Tu sais quoi, Lundi, laisse tomber
T'es déprimant
J'appelle Dimanche
Dimanche!
[Dimanche]: Merci pour la cuite d'hier, super
[Samedi]: Ah, donc on a plus le droit de s'amuser?
Ah ouais, donc le mec est coincé du cul quoi
On dirait Mardi
[Mardi]: Ferme-la espèce de j... jour de weekend!
[Dimanche]: Excuse-moi mais dix shots d'affilés de Vodka c'est pas trop ma vision de l'amusement, non
Maintenant, je me sens hyper mal!
J'ai envie de dégobiller!
[Jeudi]: Ouais fin en même temps si tu te réveilles tout le temps à 14 heures c'est un peu normal que t'es une mauvaise hygiène de vie
[Dimanche]: Ah, excuse-nous
Mais nous les dimanches, on est des gens détendus...
...ouais nous, on se réveille tard, on glande un peu
Et alors?
Ça te pose problème ?
[Dimanche Parfait]: Hehe, je t'arrête tout de suite mon loulou, on est pas tous pareil...
Moi, par exemple, ce matin je me suis réveillé à 7 heures...
...petit jus d'orange pressé, un petit bisous à mes enfants...
... et là tel que tu me vois je suis en train de jogger
Oh! Ça c'est le signal qui m'indique que je switch sur une marche rapide!
A bientôt!
[Dimanche]: Excuse-nous Dimanche Parfait...
Moi j'ai juste prévu un brunch et...
...et téléfoot...
... et un jogging aussi
Enfin
Mettre un jogging
[Samedi]: Tu sais quoi, tu me dégoute
Franchement, t'es pas digne d'être un jour du weekend
[Dimanche]: Okay les mecs, vous avez gagné
Tu sais quoi, je vais prendre ma douche et j''arrive
[Samedi]: YES
[Lundi]: Hé Dimanche!
Toi qui as la belle vie, je te rappelle qu'il faut que tu fasses tes devoirs pour demain
[Dimanche]: Ah non les gars!
Y'a Lundi qui est en train de me déprimer là!
[Samedi]: Lundi !!!
[Lundi]: C'est la triste réalité les mecs, c'est tout
[Dimanche]: Bah tu sais quoi moi je vais me foutre sous ma couette je vais regarder une série et je vais manger des sushis
[Pleure]
[Mardi]: Tu sais c'est pas la peine de pleurer hein tu sais  moi je travaille tous le temps et je suis heureux
D'ailleurs comme on dit le travail c'est la santé hein
donc sèche sort toi les doigts du cul et mets toi au boulot hein parce que ...
[Jour Férié]: *chuchote à Mardi*
[Mardi] J'ai carrément changé d'avis je suis totalement  chaud pour aller en club on y va ou pas ? Allez !!!
[Lundi] Ah d'accord donc Samedi, Dimanche et Mardi, tout le monde sort et moi je suis nul et moi je travail et voilà ma vie c'est trop de la pure merde *pleurs*
[Pont]: *chuchote à Lundi*
[Lundi] Ah ça va carrément mieux en fait
euh, bah je sors avec vous
Ouais !! Je paye des shots *tir*
[Vendredi et Samedi] : YES  !
[Dimanche] Attend, ça veut dire que je suis pas obligé de faire mes devoirs
[Lundi] Bah non, vu que je travaille pas aujourd’hui, tes devoirs on peut clairement dire que ...
on s'en bat les couilles
Ouais !!
[Dimanche] oh putain !
[Mercredi] Ah ouais génial, merci les mecs
allez, éclatez vous bien pendant que je m'occupe des petits morveux
super
[Enfant à gauche] Des quoi ?
[Mercredi] Alors, la recette de la pâte à sel
c'est simple, euh, c'est de la farine et de l'eau
[Jeudi]  *souffle*
Super les vacances scolaires
super
grosse éclate
[Mercredi] Et ça va les mecs, attend vous pouvez être un peu solidaire
moi c'est toute l'année que je me les tapes
[Mardi] Hé j'ai une idée, si on faisait un peu nos devoirs là, pour prendre un peu d'avance
[Vendredi] oh c'est bon, on les ferra Dimanche soir la dernière seconde comme d'hab'
[Dimanche] Et oh pourquoi toujours moi là ?
[Vendredi] Parce qu'après toi, on rebosse et tout
[Lundi] *pleure*
[Jeudi] On est bien là, on est bien
ouais ouais, allez, c'est bon *siffle*
[Mardi] Non ?
[Enfant] de quoi ?
[Mardi] *rire*
Pff, je sais même plus lequel je dois mettre
bah on s'en fout
[vidéo dans la vignette " à voir aussi"] OK ! le stress est maximal!
Ahh !!
J'ai très très peur
Ok on est parti les gars je suis dans l'hélico'